如果他没有考上好的大学，
他现在已经18岁了，
他现在已经是一个成年人了，
他自己必须要去面对养活自己的这个责任了，
你作为姐姐，
你千万不要上来就给他托底，
千万不要上来就说姐姐有口吃的，
姐姐不会饿着，
你千万不要。
爸爸在去年年底去世了，
妈妈在今年的七月底去世了，
我现在遇到的困境我想要跟你聊一下，
根据我自己目前的经济情况，
我该要怎么样去平衡照顾好我自己和目前家里的关系。
第二个问题是可能不太知道说怎么跟家里的亲戚去相处，
我的经济情况目前是我的月薪，
后续社保之后，
目前平均在大概六前，
我也是大专和我读了一个插本，
助学贷款有个大概五六万，
姐姐呢，
她是九七年的，
所以今年应该是28岁了，
我是24岁，
她的工作的情况的话，
目前是待业，
弟弟的话呢，
目前是高中生，
爸妈去世前其实是有在贷款一个房子的，
因为我爸爸他后面应该是搞投资还是创业吧，
到期有大几十。
呃，
当时房子又还没有盖完，
他的去世跟经济压力比较大有关于这样子去世了的后面只有妈妈一个人，
加上我当时还是刚刚出来工作，
所以对家里也没有说能帮助到多少，
这个房子目前是还在工作，
如果说你不继续去月供，
他就没有办法住下去了，
所以目前呢，
姐姐和弟弟都是搬出来了的，
那我因为在别的城市工作，
在租房的，
我自己这样的情况嘛，
所以我当时就没有在家里照顾到太多，
所以在他们去世之后，
我自己心里也是很愧疚的，
觉得说当时如果说再快一点长大，
或者说怎么样之类的，
也不会造成他们去世这么早，
再加上现在弟弟他还是未成年，
还有三个月就18岁，
这样子，
不知道该怎么去平衡好自己，
要怎么去照顾好家里还有自己这件事情？
家里还有别的亲人在吗？
外公外婆，
爷爷奶奶还有外婆在，
还有别的比较有缘分的亲戚在吗？
什么舅舅舅妈，
姑姑姑父，
有的妈妈有6个兄弟姐妹，
舅舅是大哥，
他还有4个妹妹。
给爸爸的话也是他是最。
找的那个，
他上面有两个哥哥，
哦，
我还有好像是三个姑妈，
我觉得是这样的姑娘啊，
你现在的这种内疚和愧疚的话，
是基于你想要早一点长大，
想要帮爸妈去承担家庭的责任，
这样的话，
爸妈可能就不会这么早去世，
但这个是大可不必的，
你说快点长大这个事情他不是人力所能及的，
你现在二十四四岁，
你现在已经一个月能挣6000块钱了，
而且你读大学的时候还是助学贷款，
你已经减轻了父母的很大的负担了，
你现在能把你自己的大学贷款还上，
你就很棒了，
养活自己就已经很牛了。
至于说弟弟这一块子的话，
我的想法是这样的，
亲戚朋友当中总有心比较善的，
总有日子过得宽裕一点的，
你的弟弟读大学的话，
就问这个心比较善一点的，
日子宽裕一点的，
舅舅也好，
姑姑也好，
伯伯也好，
就问他们借点钱，
你弟弟毕业了之后，
他自己再来还这个钱是吧？
亲戚之间借钱嘛，
也没有什么利息，
他就是一个情分，
但是你不要打肿脸充胖子，
说你去管你弟弟的吃喝，
管你弟弟的生活费，
你能管上自己就不错了，
自己有什么能力就干什么事儿，
到哪个山唱哪个歌，
你能把你自己的助学贷款还上，
你就很棒了，
你能在相亲市场上作为一个二十几岁的姑娘。
没有负债的情况下，
跟人家相亲，
跟人家搞对象就很好了，
没有任何的就后顾之忧了。
至于你姐姐，
她已经28岁了，
她怎么样，
她都能养活他自己，
你不用管他，
她管你借钱没有，
怎么说呢？
的确我原本也是下我和姐你这样的想法的，
但是蛮现实的，
我的爸妈的兄弟姐妹们，
他们都是说没有冥讲，
但是也会说他们能过好自己就很不错了。
有的时候我跟你说姐妹啊，
有的时候未达目的，
不择手段，
就是你弟弟想要读这个大学，
你弟弟想要有大学的学费，
如果说在亲戚朋友这边一圈下来都半个子儿都没有的话，
咱找一找当地的村委会居委会，
找一找当地的那些做企业做的比较好的，
咱就是借钱，
我如果我考上了大学，
我要么我申请国家助学贷款，
我的生活费我就是借，
甚至你知道我最难的时候啊，
我管老师借过钱，
真的，
我在读高中的时候，
最难的时候就爸妈给不起生活费的时候，
我管老师借过生活费。
不管怎么样，
这个书要读下去，
前途要往前奔，
在现在我爸妈都不在了，
我自己没有前途的时候，
我自己还不够强大的时候，
我可以拉下脸来求一切可以求的人是物，
但之后对那自自己还。
对，
他也可以申请国家助学贷款，
同时到了学校里面也有各种助学金，
也有各种助学岗，
只要自己能够为了自己的前途，
可以放下年轻时的脸面和尊严的话，
我觉得对他来说可能未来更有出息。
我不光问老师借过钱，
我还问我的同学的家长借过钱，
我不光是问同学的家长借过钱，
连我们学校门口炒粉的那个阿姨，
我还赊过账，
这个星期没有钱，
阿姨我可不可以先吃，
我下个星期我给你备点米来还你。
我都干过这个事儿，
没错，
主要是得自己要有这个够承担，
当父母不在了之后，
自己就是一颗野草，
所有的阳光雨露，
营养成分都得去吸收。
其实这个话呢，
我弟弟还是听了这么多年嘛，
耳濡目染，
我的三观跟你还是比较相近的，
但是像弟弟的话，
还有姐姐的话，
他们是被父母堡的太好了，
前面并没有很清爽的能够去捋清楚，
因为弟弟他在爸妈去世之后，
大概妈去世之后大概是8月份这样子吧，
突然之间说头痛什么的，
后面去看了各种医生，
没有生理性上的毛病，
后面就医生就说你还是去带他去看一下神经科吧，
精神类之类的就查出来了。
轻度抑郁，
轻度焦虑，
这样子他目前是比较封闭的这个状态来，
姑娘啊，
坦率的说，
他也未必能考上好的大学，
如果他没有考上好的大学，
他现在已经18岁了，
他现在已经是一个成年人了，
他自己必须要去面对养活自己的这个责任了，
你作为姐姐，
你千万不要上来就给他托底，
千万不要上来就说姐姐有口吃的，
姐姐不会饿着，
你千万不要，
刚跟她讲了，
后面是我六姨四姨，
他们跟我说，
你这样子不就是跟你妈妈在世前一样吗？
这样子是害了你弟弟。
他们就这样子给我提了一嘴，
哦，
才知道好像还真是因为他目前就是仗着他的那个，
也不是仗着吧，
但我感觉他不想站起来，
人是很难把自己饿死的，
你下次就跟他说，
你还了助学贷款了，
你确实是不够吃饭了，
你真的没有钱了，
也不用说去害怕说自己经济不好，
弟己会觉得自卑啊这样子之类的，
对不对？
在生存的面前自卑算个屁啊，
在能不能吃饱饭的事儿的面前，
脸面自卑算个屁呀？
我跟你说，
我如果说饿急眼了啊，
我可以走到人家餐馆那儿就坦诚的跟人家说，
我没钱了，
我饿急眼了，
我给你洗碗，
你给我口饭吃行不行。
我觉得太。
看到了明白，
因为弟弟他是有这个情况的话，
他是因为扛不住亲戚的那些问候，
因为他们是后面出去租别的房子了，
其实亲戚们也是挺照顾我们的了，
有去帮忙搬家呀，
落地在新的租房的地方之后呢，
也有很经常上门去照顾一下我姐和我弟的情绪方面，
害怕他们呆在家里没有人说话什么之类的，
其实就是别人只是这个本意，
但是他们就会比较抵触，
很抵触，
说老师上门，
我弟弟他当时去看心理医生的时候，
心理医生就问他们是不是有人际关系方面的压力，
他说是的，
然后又问他之后自己的人生怎么走，
比较迷茫什么之类的，
他都说是经济上有压力，
对不对，
他说是，
我后面就做了一个决定，
我就说那你挑不过来跟我一起生活吧，
我现在住的是3000一个月，
算上水电费，
夏天这样子也要去到差不多1000块了，
我当时想说他搬过来我这边，
搬离了另外一个城市，
如果说他不会处理这些事情，
那就在我身边拍着我比较坚强，
我的精神上也可以帮他，
让他看到我是这么坚强的，
就算爸妈去世了，
我也每天有坚持上班，
不会说让他在家里，
在我老家的那个城市跟我姐姐一起生活。
因为。
姐姐她现在也比较还没有站起来，
所以可能两个人住在一起的精神方面都会有影响，
所以我当时下了这么个决定，
说他搬过来我这边，
我换到一个两室一厅的，
那算上各种费用，
大概一个月是要花到一千六一千七，
如果说现在又跟您连线了，
连线这个点又已经是做了这些决定了，
而且已经跟他讲了，
我们也已经基本上敲定了之后他要搬过来的日期之类的，
我们找房子什么之类的已经敲定了，
是这样，
姑娘如果已经敲定了，
就先这样，
看你的自己的打算，
如果他想考大学，
就按照我刚才那个思路，
在亲戚朋友这一圈啊，
咱们可以借钱嘛，
打借条嘛，
是吧，
能供上读完大学，
如果说他考不上，
他也不想考的话，
那就找工作，
满18岁了，
找工作合法的，
哪怕先做快递员，
哪怕先做送餐都可以，
他必须要自己养活自己，
而不能伸手管你要生活费，
哪怕给人做个网管，
哪怕给人做个保安，
他必须要自己养活自己。
他先过来跟我住着，
我可以去跟他讲，
说我自己也要还国家贷款，
我现在其实经济压力也很大，
你其实也要出去工作，
帮忙分担一下了，
不是分担，
他自己养活自己是天经地义的事儿，
他满了18岁了，
他己讨口饭。
时是他生而为人该有的最起码的这样一个能力，
我自己会害怕，
说那他会不会又现金了，
爸爸去世了，
姐姐弟弟都是，
起码大学还是有爸妈给生活费，
我现在什么都没有，
我什么都要靠自己啊，
又让他现进了我，
其实其实我跟你讲啊，
姐妹啊，
一个人为了吃饱饭在动脑筋的时候是很难抑郁的，
你去看一下荒野求生你就知道了，
一个我，
因为我现在就是这样的状态，
我现在就是说我都没有人靠了呀，
而且本来就是爸妈在事的时候，
已经那个时候经济很困难了，
我出来了，
我就是得要靠自己，
我种情绪很低落的时候，
但是我压根就没有时间去对一个人，
他在想要喂饱自己的兔子这件事情，
在努力的时候很难抑郁，
你看荒野求生里面那些人，
天天想着抓这个蚂蚱炸那个泥鳅，
天天想着干这个事儿的时候，
他很难抑郁，
他没有抑郁的资格，
记住了，
那还有另外一个就是刚刚讲的亲戚吗？
呃，
简单粗暴，
谁对你好有联系，
对你不好的都可以拉黑，
亲戚在我这里的话，
就只分对我好的和对我不好的，
不分远近，
不分血缘，
那就这样了啊，
你弟弟也可以去考一下，
看能不能当兵，
他目前还要吃药什么之类的，
如果他有了梦想，
他自己会克服的啊，
我还有最后一点，
我想问一下亲戚那边，
他的确有一些是对我们还是好的，
但是。
不知道为什么，
老是有时候还是会提到爸爸在世的时候有风光过，
但是风光那一阵对他们其实是有照顾的，
但是照顾的他们讲出来有疏忽啊，
怎么疏忽，
其实还是埋怨居多。
姑娘，
我给你举一个例子啊，
我记得是上海滩有一个黑帮老大，
黑帮老大他在去世的时候专门干了一件事儿，
这个黑帮老大这些年借出去的钱是成百上千，
十万八万的，
到处都借了钱，
他当着所有的亲人朋友的面干了一件事儿，
就是把所有的借条全都烧掉，
就是他死了之后，
他的儿女就不会再去问他这些借钱的人去要债了，
什么意思呢？
如果你的爸爸妈妈曾经对他们有过什么帮助啊，
你绝口不能再提了，
如果你的爸爸妈妈曾经提携过他们啊，
帮衬过他们啊，
你从此口不能提了。
反过来讲，
如果你的亲戚朋友现在在埋怨你的爸爸妈妈或者怎么样的话，
不管他嘴上再埋怨，
但他实际上给了你钱，
实际上给了你的温暖，
实际上给了你衣服，
实际上给了你一口吃的，
又不能说我又当又利，
我一方面又要拿人家的钱，
另一方面我连听别人抱怨都不可以，
那是不行的。
好的，
就是你的爸爸妈妈曾经对他们有什么帮助的话，
从此你们姐妹三人绝口不提人家现在对你们的恩情的话，
等于是新开一个回合，
他们对于你的任何帮助都是恩情，
明白就这样啊，
好。
借不？
有没有觉得龙飞姐讲这那种江湖气非常重，
我感觉自己是还大老似的，
好多人就问我说龙飞你1000，
你管这个借钱，
管那个借钱，
你都还了吗？
我都还，
我拆东墙补西墙的还，
我这个月管老师借了100块钱，
我说我下个月还你，
我下个月管我那同学的父母借了200块钱，
我先把老师借100块钱还上，
我再下个月的时候我再管老师借300块钱了，
我再把这个同学把200块钱还上，
我拆东墙补西墙，
我总能熬到，
说我爸妈给我点生活费，
我再能把这些债务都清完，
所以说我的信用极高，
我不光管老师能借到钱，
我和我同学的爸妈能借到钱，
我连管保卫科的叔叔我都能借到钱，
门口炒粉的阿姨嘛，
她每次给我和我的高中的闺蜜炒粉的时候，
因为她知道我跟我高中的闺蜜是两个人吃一盒粉，
两个人吃一盒炒饭，
当他发现这个事儿的时候，
她每次给我们炒饭的时候就，
哎呀，
给我们盒饭呀，
好多饭在里头，
我跟我高中那个闺蜜我俩就分开，
大概两块钱呢，
一个炒粉，
两块钱一个炒饭，
我俩就分开吃炒饭，
后来时间长了之后，
我俩就觉得特别不好意思，
我俩分别从家里面扛个20斤大米，
就给那个炒饭的那个大姐表示表达对她的感谢，
你知道吗？
真的我还能从大姐那儿赊账，
那个姐姐我没有生活费了，
我先挂账行不行？
他说可以。
我甚至连去医院去取药，
去打针，
我都能跟医院的医生姐姐哥哥说，
我下个月再来给这个药费可不可以，
可以，
真个是，
你们可能听上去觉得很心酸对不对？
但是我从来没有觉得这件事儿有什么大不了的，
一旦我把我的贫穷，
把我的出生的卑微变成了我的保护色了之后，
他反而会成为我的通行证，
谁能懂我这个点？
这就是为什么我承认我自卑，
我的自卑也是我的武器，
我的自卑也是我的手段，
也是我达到目的可以运用的东西。
记得点赞关注哦。